[Music]
you'll come back right
all right so the plan one more time we
won't take any official crossing i think
you know that right
so there's this old smuggling tunnel
forgotten
we'll aim to use that it's near the wall
so you found a gate in the wall clever
not in as much as under it's one of
those old smuggling tunnels
thankfully it's still open it wasn't the
easiest thing to locate after all these
years
but now nothing can stop us now
look tunnels cool and all but we gotta
get there first
what about security up and down the
border whole area's brimming with tech
drones on perpetual patrol heavier stuff
too maybe
don't worry we know what's there and
what to do about it
and carolyn cassidy will keep the
corporals off our tail
great once we've crossed what then we'll
make for our meeting point join the rest
of our people there
then we'll move on towards tucson once
there
we call the shots right we know the
roads like the back of our hand
and down in arizona we have some old
favors to call in
so even if i wanted to i got nothing to
worry about
starting today it's not all on your back
you're no longer alone v
you'll get used to it it's nice
looks like i've got a debt of gratitude
to pay now oh come the [ __ ] on
we're all riding in the same wagon and
thanks to you we stole enough arisa tech
to build an aircraft carrier believe me
on the list of those wanted dead or
alive our names are right under yours
well time to move before that storm
finds us
so
we're ready after you pan am
are we all set
so jack in let's get the hell out of
here
you got it
this is your big new beginning so you
have to start it like a real nomad
behind the proverbial wheel mostly go
straight
go around the bigger holes and don't
lose the rest got it
i will deal with the nitro the mix will
go straight to the cylinders
if i don't sink it just right manually
it could blow us to bids
i think that's best avoided [ __ ]
i just realized something what's wrong
the border wall when i was little it
wasn't there obviously
but i sensed everything was different in
the north that's something great
awaiting me there
a bright [ __ ]
i know what comes next once you wound up
on the other side and nothing changed
you thought
night city was the answer everything
would change there
yes and you know the tales end too
i'm returning right back to where i
started no i'd be the same place in the
other side
same space but you're different totally
different
all in all
then hit it home stretch full speed
ahead
they've launched the drones
get them off your tail go on kids
see you on the other side
the nitro is ready say goodbye to night
city
it's your last chance
[Music]
they'll get you if you stray too wide
starter up
the wheel is yours let's ride
exactly what you wanted a new beginning
slow down pan am not
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
it's perfect all great pan am
we're going home
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey v how's life out there in the desert
getting some sun some fresh air in those
lungs
don't forget to get yourself a checkup
every once in a while
any dust or dirt gets into that
insulation
you're done of course decent ripper is
harder to find out there than a
four-star hotel
so actually how about you just stop by
when you're back in the city huh
think i could swing a little discount
for an old regular like you
till next time
hey v long time no see
let me guess you still the top of your
game in all of night city
yeah i left all that
i guess i'm just calling to say thanks
for everything wasn't until i left
everything behind that i realized how
depressed i was for all that time
take it from me v if you ever get the
chance
just leave leave and don't look
back the weight it takes off your
shoulders i
can't even describe it
all right love lecturing
take it easy
p hey christ that run we did
my heart's still pounding the pack of
nomads versus arasaka
oh i mean the odds were totally stacked
against us
i didn't know if we'd get out alive but
hey we made it
and you know why because you were the
one leading the charge fee
the craziest baddest merc from pacifica
to the apple agents
i don't know what you're up to right now
what your plans are
but just remember we've walked through
hell and back with you brother anytime
until next time eh take care
hey rogue here i wanted to oh
voicemail why not
v i was wondering if you could pass the
message along to johnny
two messages actually one
that he's an arrogant egotistical son of
a [ __ ]
and second that it was nice to talk to
him again
both of you take care of yourselves okay
hey so funny thing just [ __ ] [ __ ] shake
voicemail again
do you ever answer the phone like ever
seriously
i can get through the data term customer
service faster than you
what did i even oh yeah yeah you know
that us
cracks agent called me and asked if i
would go on
tour with them at first i was like oh my
dead [ __ ] body
but then i thought hey wait i could
actually be fine
so who knows well
there's the latest gossip for you if you
even care
call me back when you can okay peace out
hey so here's the thing couple fellas
from the fifth precinct busted a shop
selling illegal iron
sawed-offs stun guns mustard gas
canisters
orders from on up were to blow it all to
the ground
but then i thought maybe there's a
better way to use all this stuff
for a good cause i still remember what
you did for us
for me and randy the city needs more
people like you
i want to make sure they're equipped
this one's on me
see you around
before samurai commented
they wrote to say a death boy
it contained their final thoughts about
life about death i have read many of
them of late
some were truly works of beauty
yet i am not a samurai so i beat you
very well with the simple words
rock inhale sorrow
[Music]
hey it's perales
first you need to go somewhere no one's
listening
okay so my wife elizabeth
she's in on the whole thing she
she keeps saying i should look after
myself tells me to take these
pills says their vitamins got them
analyzed at a lab
and they look okay but but how am i
supposed to know if somebody didn't
falsify the results
call me okay oh yeah and don't forget to
delete this message
[Music]
hey v listen i was just thinking about
you
so i laid out a quick tarot i know
i know the reading's not as strong
without you here but we haven't seen
each other for so long and i
well one thing led to another you know
what i drew
the chariot the lovers and the sun
looks like you've got a good life ahead
of you out in the badlands
good luck v be free
cause we lost everything
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
mmm